what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and The Flash movie is one of the most
talked about movies out there it is one
of the most anticipated superhero films
coming up but it also does have a lot of
controversy surrounding it due to the
trouble that Ezra Miller has gotten into
however the trailer that we got for this
movie was one of the best trailers ever
and it really does make it seem like
this movie truly does have the potential
to be an amazing superhero film and
today we have some really cool details
about the movie specifically in regards
to Batman and Affleck's Batman that is
not Michael Keaton's but Ben Affleck's
Batman his new suit and a major Cameo
that is going to be happening in The
Flash Film we also hear Ben Affleck talk
in an interview about how he finally
found his Batman how it finally clicked
with him in his head so he finally
figured out which type of Batman and
Bruce Wayne he personally is it's sad
that this is most likely the last time
we'll see him play Bruce Wayne Batman
because I would have loved to have seen
what he had to offer for future movies
and hey the Multiverse is real The Flash
is opening up the Multiverse so you
never really know we'll have to wait and
see so to start it off we have a new
look at Ben Affleck's new Batman suit in
The Flash Film and this is coming via
toy League the infamous toy leaks that
always seem to get out somehow and
always give us some decent information
about the film including our first look
at this new Batman suit now we briefly
saw a glimpse of his new suit in the
trailer that they released and we saw
that it is more blue and gray and
overall lighter than his normal suit and
as we can see here from the figure it
looks like he has a lot more metal on
this suit that could possibly be to
protect him from bullets it could also
possibly be for new gadgets which I am
personally hoping that we do get to see
in this film even though his characters
probably only going to be in it for the
beginning of the film before Barry
decides to time travel and essentially
screw up the entire Multiverse now this
is a seven inch scale figurine and it's
coming from McFarlane Toys and if
anybody is interested in this figurine
you can pre-order it now from McFarlane
Toys but with this also comes a look at
his new bike his new motorcycle we also
saw this a little bit in the trailer as
well it's got two tires up front and one
in the back it does have similarities to
Christian Bale's bat motorcycle in the
Dark Knight trilogy however it does have
many differences as well the two tires
on the front being the major one so
that's our better look at Batman's new
suit it may be possible that he wears
more than one suit in the movie we'll
have to wait and see on that but now
let's talk about the major Cameo that
Ben Affleck himself actually spoiled in
a recent interview this is also where he
talked about finally finding his Batman
so recently Ben Affleck was on the
smartless podcast and he started talking
about his time in the dceu now if you
haven't really kept up to date with
everything Ben Affleck to said recently
he has said that he would not direct
anything for James gunz's new DC
Universe and this mainly comes from kind
of trauma that he has from working with
DC in the past the whole Snyder cut
Justice League movement losing the
director getting a new one having the
movie not be very successful how hard it
was for him to film sadly it just
doesn't sound like Ben Affleck wants to
be involved with DC anymore which is sad
because he did want to direct a Batman
movie and it's also sad because like I
said before Ben Affleck says he has
finally figured out how to play Batman
and this is actually where the spoiler
comes from as well in the podcast he
said and he describes a scene here so
spoilers upcoming but he says I finally
figured out how to play the guy that was
like hold on am I is that I quit I know
I quit and I know came back but I got it
now it's like you know when you do the
audition and you're on your way home
you're like oh I mean I don't want to
give a spoiler but it was a scene where
I get caught I get saved by Wonder Woman
during a conflagration with some bad
guys which is a big fire and he says and
she saves me I I mean I'm sure the
spoiler DC assassins are gonna get me
but she saves me with the lasso of Truth
and so what happens is that Batman
divulges some of his real feelings about
his life and his work I was like wait a
minute I got it so two things here two
major things obviously the huge spoiler
is the Gal Gadot Wonder Woman Cameo
She's popping up a lot recently if
you've seen some recent DC movies you
know what I mean actually they spoiled
her Cameo for that movie in the trailer
so I'm wondering if they're going to do
that for the Flash in a TV spot or the
next trailer we'll have to wait and see
on that we basically know that DC and
Warner Brothers are trying to get people
really excited and interesting in these
new movies that are also going to be
kind of old movies when the new DCU
starts so they're kind of trying to
throw cameo videos in trailers and TV
spots so we get excited and want to go
see the movie but it's funny that Ben
Affleck has revealed this and now it's
out there Wonder Woman is going to be in
a scene with Batman and she's going to
save him and apparently she is going to
get the lasso of Truth around him and
that's gonna make him in turn tell the
truth and he's going to kind of confess
his true feelings about being Batman and
in turn I think this is sort of going to
be Ben Affleck's feelings about playing
Batman because he says that this scene
is finally what caused it to click with
him in his head how he portrays Batman
how he is Batman and that's the other
big thing Ben Affleck seems to have
finally nailed down the part for himself
at least I personally think he did a
pretty good job on the other films I
know that opinion isn't shared by
everyone but he is a great Batman to me
I enjoyed him and this really is a
bummer to hear especially since he has
recently said that he doesn't really
want anything to do with DC anymore
however I will say there could be a
little bit of Hope here if The Flash
movie is received very well and if he is
received very well in that movie if he
has some good scenes and he does a great
job and the fans love it and he is
feeling like he has finally figured out
how to play Batman for himself and he
gets a lot of love at snydercon which he
may or may not go to but if he does and
he gets a lot of love well that could
possibly open up that door for him again
the door of him being open to possibly
reprise his role as Batman slash Bruce
Wayne down the line in the new DCU
somewhere we know they're going to
tackle the Multiverse in some way shape
or form we know that James Gunn was
willing to work with him we know that
James Gunn said that he did want him to
direct if they found the proper project
for him so there is possibility there
and James Gunn has even talked about
this with Gal Gadot as well no there
isn't going to be a Wonder Woman 3 but
he said that he is still speaking with
her about what possibilities there could
be with her in this new universe the
same thing goes for Henry Cavill
Superman James Gunn hasn't closed the
possibility of Henry cavill's Superman
showing up in the new DCU ever he simply
said that with the story they're telling
they are getting a younger Superman but
again with the Multiverse anything is
possible they could return they could
simply be in Another Universe and the
universes could Collide in one big event
someday they may try to do crisis on
infinite Earths who knows but it does
kind of sound like the plans before
James Gunn took over with Peter Safran
sounds like the plans were to have more
crossovers with all of our heroes Wonder
Woman has now appeared in Shazam 2 for a
very brief moment we have Ben Affleck
appearing in The Flash and now Gal Gadot
is appearing in the flash as well
there's a lot of crossover here but in
reality they didn't really have a plan
before The Rock was kind of doing his
own thing bringing back Henry Cavill but
it was also kind of trying to control
Shazam cameos at the same time while
clearly other people at Warner Brothers
were planning for these big crossovers
so it was kind of a mess it's a great
thing that James Gunn is coming in and
hopefully this new reboot is for the
better and hopefully no doors are closed
as far as the old DCU Justice League
coming into the new DCU and just making
cameos maybe multiversal cameos I think
it would be really cool but let me know
your thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe to stay up to
date on the latest DCU news you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf
foreign